[Music]
on this first day of the month when rent
is due for so many americans we're going
to highlight the country's looming
eviction crisis
a federal moratorium on evictions runs
out at the end of this month
after that people who owe back rent
could be forced out of their homes at
the beginning of the year
an estimated 10 million renters were
behind owning a combined
57 billion with a b dollars in rent and
utilities
our national correspondent that's jerica
duncan shows us the toll on renters and
the building's owners
adjuster fernandez describes life these
days
as hanging on by a thread how have these
last 11 months been for you tough
i would say traumatic how much do you
owe in rent right now
close to twenty thousand close to twenty
thousand dollars
yeah for about four years fernandez has
been living with a roommate
in a second story apartment within a
house in queens new york
before the pandemic were you behind on
your rent no never
i've never had an eviction issue never
had a run
issue fernandez says it was a tough
decision at the beginning of the
pandemic
to not start a new job as a home health
aide but a necessary one
because of asthma and other medical
conditions
it's either i rest myself to die
and pay the rent and still die or
i stay home safe the risk is real for
fernandez whose mother was hospitalized
after contracting the virus
she literally was in critical condition
the doctors told me and the nurses told
me that she wasn't going to make it on
december 25th and we were preparing for
her
to just pass away thankfully she pulled
through
but it also was eye-opening for me like
i made the right decision for myself
currently fernandez is working a
part-time job from
home bringing in some twelve hundred
dollars a month
and fernandez's roommate lost her job at
the beginning of the pandemic
making their 1800 dollar monthly rent
payments
impossible what happens if you're
evicted
it's dead of winter right now i don't
know i really don't know
as state and federal moratoriums are
expected to expire in the next few
months
an estimated 30 to 40 million americans
are at risk of being evicted
black and latino people make up
approximately 80 percent of those facing
eviction
but it's not just renters landlords say
they're feeling the pressure too how
many of your tenants are behind right
now
they're all behind in one way or another
liz dunn owns six buildings in seattle
washington
it's made up of more than 20 small
businesses and nearly 30 apartments
my entire goal is to try and keep every
one of my tenants
in their space until we are all the way
through this
dunn admits that's been difficult she's
accepting less in rent from tenants
and has been directing them to grants
and loans how are you able to afford
your tenants at grace to say you know
what just chalk it up to
the pandemic and when you can start
paying me in full we'll move forward
well that's where the local banks come
in so they're affording me the same
grace
for example i'm getting help with
not having to pay principal on the loan
just making the interest payments
for renters who don't have a landlord
like dunn there may be some relief
coming soon
the federal government's emergency
rental assistance program went into
effect in january
25 billion dollars is being made
available to states
to help assist qualified households with
rent and utilities
but experts say it may not be enough
i've never been in a situation like this
for fernandez who recently applied for
food stamps
the future is uncertain they literally
said
you make three dollars more so i wasn't
poor enough to get assistance
but i didn't have enough to be able to
survive
what are you most concerned about when
you think about your situation and the
more than 40 million
americans in this country who are on the
verge of being kicked out of their
apartments
i'm thinking this is gonna further
create a
homeless crisis i want people to know
that this can happen to anybody
fernandez and her roommate were taken to
court housing court by the landlord we
did reach out to the landlord for
comment
but did not hear back tarika this has
got to feel overwhelming
what can be done to help those like ms
fernandez who are facing eviction
you know we spoke to a housing expert
and they said that this is a big issue
mainly because of that background and
that 25 billion dollars that the
government has set aside
is used to help those renters and
landlords with that background
but you have to apply and on top of that
it's really up to the states and local
governments as to how that money is
distributed experts say
the bottom line here the issue is best
addressed through policy changes and
making more affordable housing
available gail all right thank you very
much